this week we got eyebrow brawl what
funky sister and hey there Delilah we're
tribute Banga Banga bang fur story
they're crazy fights in Brooklyn and
Nelson Oakland after there was this
customer who complained about her
eyebrows being all messed up and so she
didn't want to pay that five dollars and
their report saying that head dolls do
eyebrows really good Joe I saw this
video yo yeah and then some reported
that will happen at already keep cutting
along that she started hitting the nail
technician started hitting her with a
laptop
[Applause]
thanks to do the sign of holding comic
career send up their classes these
started attacking the ladies black
people against the Chinese people it's
just a family I mean the main thing is
that you see is that the broom fighting
did you saw this and what I and well I
don't know about any of the new stuff
they came out I just saw it and I just
took it for what it is
so I don't know what the whole story is
but you know this is like specifically
why there's such a split between like
Asian of black communities right so
there's not feel like they're in that
video dish and then they're [ __ ]
hating on the glooms and [ __ ] there's
like this thing about like Asian
communities because there's a lot of
Asian businesses that open up in black
communities right they do that I give
nail salons beauty supplies whatever
right and so there I've never seen this
happen though before so this one's
pretty [ __ ] extreme right yeah cuz
usually Asians are scared yeah yeah
usually you don't see that [ __ ] you know
to me like I've seen my mom get beat up
the other way around yeah yeah
like people I literally punch my mom the
chairs and hold chest bruise death
because she she tried to steal some [ __ ]
and my mom told her just leave it I was
there and my mom's like leave it and
then you could just leave it she goes I
didn't steal anything
it was like speaker purse I think you
know but just leave it and go and the
Sheila's swung on my mom and then like
bruised my mom's chest and then you know
we had to call the cops you got arrested
yeah you know but like to see the other
way around is kind of like uncommon for
me but this is sucks because like you
know there's this whole thing of like I
feel like the black community Mike I
haven't seen any video after this but
there's like the black
community supports these Asian
businesses you know what I mean and so
now I feel like a lot of the black
community like we should support our own
businesses at this point because like we
shouldn't be taking this type of
treatment which is [ __ ] true because
when I see that I'm like yeah that's
[ __ ] wild dude there's no way you
should be swinging a [ __ ] broom on
somebody no matter what the product is
they're throwing acetone - that's
[ __ ] wild you don't understand like
that's so crazy those ladies that's
[ __ ] up [ __ ] smells good hey nail
salon smell that [ __ ] I don't know how
that smells but I know that so when I
got into my sister's like asses on to
smell it I think that's why all my brain
doesn't quite work probably yeah yeah
yeah
that sponge in there I [ __ ] love that
[ __ ] huh yeah so they were saying that
apparently the the eyebrow thing like
half of her eyebrows waxed off and
that's when she got mad oh okay she
didn't want to pay for the $5 me
eyebrows but then the no technisches are
saying that she didn't want to pay for
any other services she got that day
which were her nails as well how come
your family open up in a black
neighborhood because a lot of these the
beauty supplies are actually Korean
companies and so my parents didn't speak
any English
hmm so the only way they can they open
up businesses where they can communicate
with the salesman and that's beauty
supplies you know so that's that's
generally how like these things work out
so you mean the all the factories that
make Black Beauty Supply is a lot of
mercury oh wow a lot of these salesmen
are Korean as well so you think that
people should only shop with the stores
of oh that are owned by the room no it's
like I think for that it's like if
there's this thing about like that's
what I heard a lot it's like I'm not
shopping I'm only gonna go to like the
black people who you know support the
business and if that's how they feel
them that's understandable just because
like if that's the type of treatment
that they're getting from this community
because like the way that you can like
really shut down a businesses through
their dollars mm-hmm you know and I
think like that's the stuff that I heard
a lot you know growing up you know just
because they felt like number one like
especially with my parents or if they
had a bad experience for some other
store it would transfer over to
our store it's like you're always trying
to think that we're gonna steal bump
blah blah and it's not you people it's a
black beauty supply store everybody's
black so you're just customers yeah
literally there's only like a fluttering
of like three or four white people that
will come in a week yeah and then they
walk in and they go like it was such a
hard thing like I don't know how to
explain it like it's not it's not it's
not a black thing like literally I grew
up in a in a black community around all
black people it's just everybody is
black so there's customers that do steal
when you have a black beauty supply
store they're called like Black Beauty
Supplies yeah
is it really yeah that's funny yeah it's
not cuz there's Beauty Supply stores and
there's a black new supply store all
african-american care products right all
right so we sell a lot of stuff that's
you know weaves wigs
chemical products anything that has to
do with like african-american skin
products or or haircare oh so that's
what club that you select yeah so after
all this they started protesting outside
of the nail shop and as of right now
it's still clothes they don't know when
it's gonna be open happy red apple yeah
and no matter what the situation red
what is that there's like a little bunch
of people right take your broomsticks
and fly away you witches oh that's fun
hey you know what we got a stereotype
now it's like it's so dumb for them to
do that because you are in a community
that supports your business and the
continual for five bucks let's say they
were a position let's just say I'm not
saying that they are [ __ ] cares just let
them go nothing's gonna happen
nothing's gonna [ __ ] happen is the
dumbest thing people will come into our
business they would literally try to
jack our [ __ ] my mom say the same thing
every time
just tell them to drop it and ask them
to come back another time so I've been
watching um what I would say is a
veritable [ __ ] ton of videos this show
called hardcore pawn' it's totally fake
but every episode every single episode
is somebody who's trying to pull one
over on the pawn shop owner and I just
it's just the funniest [ __ ] I don't know
how they get these these people because
they have them act pretty good and then
half of them don't but it's always the
same thing it's like somebody walks up
with fake hearings or whatever and then
the person's like these are fake and the
person's like you call me a liar and
they start [ __ ] swinging on them
the huge like [ __ ] seven foot eight
black guy like takes the people out of
the store every [ __ ] time
jerry springer meets Pawn Stars yes oh
great right yeah so I've been really
enjoying this and and for some reason
well for many reasons that reminded me
of us you know you know it's I'd wanna
one day open up a pawn shop I would love
that
just for the clientele yes yeah so you
know how people want to make money so
they could leave yeah the [ __ ] bad
neighborhoods yeah I know I never want
to leave I just want to play I get it I
like these neighborhoods oh man it's
it's weird they like being in my parents
door because like people have this like
perception of like Asian people who
don't like like their black clientele in
these hoods right but that's not true
because like it's literally like 95% of
our customers aren't great we had we've
had we're 20-car we're turning customer
rate is huge you know but there's just
5% that just they kind of act like we
treat all of our customers that way it's
like no we treat you that way because
you're a piece of [ __ ] the other 95
percent is [ __ ] great yeah that's
normal for every retail shop is that
there is a you in accounting you have
theft already accounted for because you
know like a small percentage is just
gonna steal so well I love it when
somebody tries to steal and then they
get caught and then as they're leaving
they're like you don't go here this
place sucks they treat you like [ __ ]
yeah good legit like I'd like like so
many [ __ ] stories about people trying
to steal stuff is unreal when we were
writing guk like we were going through
all these stories like literally
somebody come into our store it was like
a hundred degrees in Sacramento wearing
a trench coat like what are you gonna do
right now yeah you know and they try to
still give us a call David a perm kick
like a perk it box by the way is like
this size I saw a video of a guy at a
Walmart and they were the guy who's
filming and it's like all of a sudden a
skylight gets kicked out and then people
everyone looks up everyone the whole
[ __ ] store looks up and this guy's
like crawling down from the ceiling
tiles you have the distraction someone
else Oh
guys are such a [ __ ] absolute [ __ ]
and any falls down that just runs up the
front door it's like what were you miss
your little bit I wanted not like can we
actually sit it down I'm like yeah I'll
talk to him dad what was your plan all
right for our next story
Missy Elliott posted this video even as
she reposted this way I love this video
so go through the screenshot of our
Instagram post you want to read her
caption yeah
message wait I just found out I have a
funky white sister cry faces many many
cry faces but hold up she brought her
homegirl to the cookout to she's the one
tiptoeing in the background with a cup
of Eagles and noodles in her hand yo sis
done made the elephant sound - I wasn't
ready for her to say put the cap on yet
what the [ __ ] like I play D I mean but
don't have me read it then she straight
up killed work it with the yeah yeah
yeah at the beginning and sound effects
and all like my funky white cyst
featuring Miss tippy-toe in the back I
have a headache not things - what is it
and the kitty part you saying [ __ ] in
the song alright here we go
oh it's a video [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
somebody call me over this is [ __ ]
amazing for karaoke as you always have
to build it up before you suck it's so
important like hey coming at you live
from the park you know how I do about to
get it got to get it on always always
you have to build it up you have to
build it up that's what I can amazing
mom watering during karaoke is so
crucial in the commitment it's like
That's Entertainment right there she
believes in herself high school physics
teacher looks exactly like that
Oh hundred pounds of you my literate my
literature teacher what's the con
everybody Disneyland looks exactly
[ __ ] everybody yeah right I have so
many questions like why is she [ __ ]
clenching on that elkhorn and like what
what's going on here what is this like
it's her brand part of her brow it's a
festival of horns so her name is Mary
she's from Rhode Island and she was just
performing the track at one part and
then someone recognized that from Missy
Elliott tweet and they tweeted back and
said oh my god it's miss Mary this Park
/ beaches in my hometown she used to be
at my friend's restaurant every Friday
night for karaoke and perform this she'd
get the whole room crazy every time
she's a sweetheart go of Mary dope
that's great all those years of
practicing and now her moment one of the
best like female like hip hop songs till
this [ __ ] dick Missy Elliott I
[ __ ] love her dude yeah do you know
another missus that's the ones that I
like the most you know any other songs
no I cannot no for me I don't like I
like Missy Elliott and an emcee like for
me I didn't connect to a lot of her
music she talked about [ __ ] and [ __ ]
but as an emcee she's a producer to do
about her [ __ ] apartment I'm like I
can't really I see I see but this [ __ ]
she's always been a dope MC her flow is
like top-notch so when a lot of like
other female artists come out I feel
like I always compare them to her she
seems to yeah she's a great singer a
great rapper and a dope artist you know
it's like for me in life like biggie
because I grew up with Tupac my whole
life but I still I don't know like I'm
probably like 3 or 4 biggie songs but I
know about like 10 to pop songs you know
I mean but I still know who biggie is
and how dope he is we have miss Flo and
that's how like Missy is to me any of
the stuff you know all the time he's
very nasally to me Queen Latifah and
Missy Elliott I'm like I'm like always
what's the difference
yeah it's the music the music sounds to
me very similar their flows way
different though once we're at time and
it ones more lighter than the other one
I just know her more as an actress who
yeah now yeah 25 when Queen Latifah on
the TiVo is known more as actually she's
more known as an act actor than amusing
that's why wants to be iconic in the hip
she was ironic though first female and
then in the 80s she was a [ __ ] dude we
have an amazing gray jelly too drunk
brothers [ __ ] dough wonders because
she would she had that song like angry
had a lot of mental issues though so we
don't watch it joke no that's all I try
to say goodbye and I choke it's only
song of hers I can maybe I'm assuming
the whole she perform like she had
promised Mexican actually have a couple
of alright for our last story you guys
remember the hey yeah from 2006 dams now
speaking of one-hit wonders [ __ ] yeah
that's crazy
so labels on the radio yesterday no dude
12 years ago so recently uh The
Hollywood Reporter said that they are
trying to create a TV show around this
song what well in writing letters to
each other what I know right there the
Lyla do I don't know that no one knows
after that right no no and no wonder I
can't name another song by the band
either hmm
I'll play a little clip here
like in new UI stocks like how Africa
house away but girl tonight you look so
pretty yes you do
yeah uh what genre of rock does this
fall into a folk surf sand yeah this is
all six sleepy sleepy surfs the rock no
go to your luck I don't know you gotta
go you know what they do when it's
always just like three strings yeah
three quarters with acoustic guitar does
that make sense yeah the problem is and
if they change him to Punk two three
strings then it's punk music for some
reason and there's more energy toys so
the front man named Tom higgenson
he will be the producer of this TV show
and yeah they were pretty much trying to
center an entire TV show around this
song we're like what the song is about
this dude who's saying that he's gonna
write a song about Delilah when like cuz
she lives in New York City and that he
that that song will make him famous and
then he'll be rich also the story embed
into the song yeah that makes sense yeah
so then they're gonna form a whole show
around that story it's not gonna last a
season I miss know I can't wait to
screaming yeah why can't they just keep
remaking [ __ ] what do I got to do this
now we've taken it too far oh my god
they hire original writers no no they're
adapting from a song that's already not
original that's his own work look
they're doing The Jeffersons I can say
she do Laverne and Shirley again just do
it all mr. Belvedere back oh yeah that's
turbo he's the butler he's a big burly
Butler let's go he's he's so nice I feel
like all the shows back in the day were
like it was like kids never had parents
it's so [ __ ] sad all the shows is
like I don't have parents cuz my parents
are working all day but I'm gonna I'm
cool with my Butler or like any of these
it's like the father figure shows mother
figure shows I feel like if I showed you
a clip you would know you Claire do you
know mr. Belvedere I know sure this is a
70s show that watch the show it's great
show if you know how much oh yeah I like
Three's Company but I never thought
they're gonna [ __ ] three ways cuz I
thought the girls were nasty no the song
was hot all right you don't know like no
no they remind me of grandmas the way
that they dress their style let me wish
you would dress so [ __ ] shows that
shortcut sure like I use this the
fashion like in my head if you're not
90s you're [ __ ] old it's like - yeah
dude when's Hanson gonna take three
bucks on their show he'll be does like
we're looking we're looking at the
lyrics and we're like there's a show in
here writes itself the boom box what's
the actual words he says in there it's
like it's like pop and they don't know
you just don't know right I just know
that part and that's as far as it went
yeah yeah yeah yeah I hated them up is a
lot basically the whole thing I said oh
yeah yeah yeah he says plant the seed
plant a flower plant - Rose there's your
show yo did you see that interview of
like the coffee 6-9 talking about his
song with Nicki that [ __ ] was [ __ ] you
mean where he's doing this one with no
so he got that song Fifi right on with
with like with Nicki right yeah and he's
like doing this radio interview and
they're like this is kids like yo man
I'm in the studio
yo legit I'm just having fun and they're
like oh but you got like
lyricism is [ __ ] but he goes the [ __ ]
are you talking about I'm going I said
Fifi got that [ __ ] got that kinky guy
that whatever he goes what the [ __ ] am i
safe radio mic person I was like yeah
but that requires flow he's like nah
seriously yeah I'm like that's true but
it's so funny too because even the radio
person's trying to give him credit he's
like are you talking about [ __ ] we we
all think that he's gonna sit there and
go when I when I was saying yeah we got
a key what I was meaning to say societal
the inequality or whatever the [ __ ] I
[ __ ] set and loves it I was like
whatever about it and now I like yeah
[Music]